as we check traffic now with hector hey
there nate well it's time to
rise and shine to a great morning on the
roadways we don't have any big crashes
or backups to worry about right now on
the highway system
so let's take a look at the 515 looks
like we have minor slowdowns for those
heading from the east side over to
the downtown area for the i-15 so let's
spy on those drivers let's take a live
look this is the 515
near las vegas boulevard i hate the
stretch of the road for those heading
northbound because
right about here that is where the lanes
sort of weave and merge and
there are some slowdowns i guess they're
moving the camera around so let's take
another look at the highway system
no backups down in henderson the
southwest or in the north part of town
however we are seeing minor slowdowns
through the resort corridor just before
right around charleston and i-15
southbound and for those who continue
heading southbound for the interchange
looks like we still have
wide open lanes closer to sunset all
right alex madame alex let's go over to
you